Speaker 1: Let's go to the phones.
You can call in on the Friday show via discord
at David Pakman dot com slash discord.
Extremely, extremely important stuff to do.
Why don't we go first to Jason from Toronto,
Canada.
Jason, welcome.
What's on your mind today, my friend?
Speaker 2: Hey, David.
How are you?
Speaker 1: I'm doing well, thank you.
Speaker 2: I just actually, I have a couple
questions for you.
One politics related.
Do you feel that as major news networks are
starting to distance themselves from Trump
in all the legal issues he's currently in,
are we seeing the slow demise of him potentially
in his movement, or do you feel that that's
still a little bit away as far as as seeing
kind of the MAGA movement kind of dwindle
down?
Speaker 1: I think we've got a long way to
go.
Right now, it's not so much that the TV networks
like Fox News, for example, are stepping away
from Trump, but they're giving themselves
other options.
In other words, they're starting to say, hey,
a lot of people seem to like DeSantis.
They're kind of building the escape hatch,
so to speak, but they haven't yet pulled the
eject button, if that makes sense.
That's the analogy, I would say.
However, I think depending on what happens
in 20, in November of 22 in the midterms and
depending on what happens in terms of the
indictments in public opinion around Trump's
indictments, if indeed he gets indicted, then
you may start to see things change.
One interesting thing is if you look at predicted,
which is betting markets, DeSantis is now
in the lead as who is expected to get the
2024 Republican nomination nomination based
on the betting numbers.
If those numbers continue to go against Trump's
favor, you might see an acceleration.
But right now, nobody's really abandoned Trump.
They're just giving themselves other options.
Speaker 2: Yeah, that makes sense.
And just the other question I have for you
as a new father, what are you enjoying most
about your experience?
I'd say like the.
Speaker 1: You know, essentially day to day
development and just seeing how things change
so much from day to day.
And, you know, she's able to do new things
and attention span goes up and ability to
just like kind of hang out without flipping
out increases.
And it really is.
I mean, certainly from week to week, it gets
very different.
Speaker 2: It's awesome.
Good to hear.
Speaker 1: All right.
Things are getting.
Speaker 2: Better.
Yeah, things are good.
The temperature here is certain to drop as
fall comes in, but otherwise, things are all
right.
Speaker 1: I mean, I can't I apologize for
this question, but there is no way you can
get a good bagel in Toronto, right?
That's a montreal thing.
Speaker 2: I mean, you can get a good bagel
in Toronto.
You can.
It's less.
It's less known.
But yeah, there are a couple of bagel shops
here in the city that are pretty good.
Wow.
Montreal's known for it.
Yeah.
Yeah, there's some pretty good places here.
Speaker 1: And smoked salmon and everything's
available.
Yep.
Incredible.
Sure.
Well, and you guys have the Internet and running
water and everything.
Speaker 2: Oh, yeah, that's.
That's.
It's amazing.
We just got cars a couple of months ago.
That's awesome.
Speaker 1: Very good.
All right, my friend.
Thank you for that call.
That was a joke, by the way.
Obviously, we love Toronto.
Thank you.
No, no offense there.
That's those are just jokes.
Everybody relax.